ich fand ganz schön dass jetzt noch im
Vorfeld des Gottesdienstes öffentlich
wurde
Königin sich eben keinen langweiligen
Gottesdienst gewünscht hat also sie
wollte einen Gottesdienst haben mit
schöner Musik und der gezeichnet ist von
Liebe und ich glaube das wird uns jetzt
erwarten
sie hätte ganz deutlich eine ihrer
letzten Wünsche war es soll nicht so
lange gehen und vor allem nicht
langweilig werden deswegen eine Stunde
Gottesdienst wollte sie den mächtigsten
und wichtigsten Menschen und Royals der
Welt zu muten sagte dann aber auch da
ganz klar das muss reichen hat sich
besonders schöne Musik ausgedacht damit
auch dort alle jetzt haben wir einen
fantastischen Blick hier einmal auf die
Krone die Krone wiegt ja 1,6 Kilo
hat sie oft getragen ja diese Krone 1,6
Kilo schwer über 68 Perlen sind habt ihr
noch weitere Details und unschätzbarem
umsetzbar
unten auch
[Musik]
ja man kann vielleicht auch noch mal auf
die auf die Flagge hier eingehen die man
sieht auf dem Sack das sind ja auch die
verschiedenen Länder dabei der rotsügige
Löwe von England dann der blauzünden von
Schottland und diese Harfe die eben für
Irland steht und normalerweise ist auch
dieser Hosenbandorden noch darauf zu
sehen aber hier auf der Plakette glaube
ich nicht noch nicht erkennen was dort
normalerweise auf dem Waffen ist der
blaue Hosenband Orden noch drauf genau
und da steht ja Französisch übersetzt
ein schelben wer Böses bei bei denkt das
ist hier der Wappenspruch
sehr ernsten Blick sehen wir hier bei
der König diesen Brief geschrieben hat
und seine Mutter aber vielleicht auch
die Enkelkinder sie hat ja auch einen
Brief hinterlassen ne ein Brief der
irgendwie erst in ganz vielen Jahren
geöffnet werden darf da weiß man aber im
Einkaufscenter aber spannend was da wo
drin steht
jetzt sind wir hier die Momente der Sarg
wird jetzt hineingetragen
300 Kilo schwerer Sarg
der schon vor 30 Jahren hergestellt
wurde wird jetzt hineingetragen und
Westminster Abbey auf dem Sarg sehen wir
ihre Krone Sinnen Reichsapfel sehen das
Zepter wunderschöne Blumen diesmal haben
sie immer bisher in Weiß gesehen jetzt
aber für diesen Moment in rosa in
dunkelrot mit dabei im übrigen Myrte
denn das hatte sie auch in ihrem
hochzeitssträußchen als sie die sind
glaube ich im Garten die Blumen
englische Eiche mit dabei Lilien
Magnolien
so hat sie sich das gewünscht und jetzt
geht es hinein in Westminster Abbey
viele verbeugen sich unter den Augen
muss man sagen der wichtigsten der
mächtigsten Menschen der Welt
2000geladene Gäste hier sehen wir König
Charles dahinter Prinzessin n seine
Schwester
ENA ist ja übrigens vom Rang her eine
Generalin und Adjutantin der Royal Navy
deswegen trägt sie auch diese Uniform
auch Camilla sehen wir jetzt hier und
Prinz George neben seinem Vater
er wird irgendwann mal König sein auch
wenn wir jetzt in weite Zukunft blicken
aber
zwei also Nummer drei ja genau ja genau
und die Charlotte
mit also ein bisschen dauern bis wieder
eine Frau dran kommt
und hier sehen wir
Prinzessin Kate von Wales und hinter ihr
meckern
[Musik]
neben George man sieht sie kaum die
kleine Charlotte ja sieht nur den Hut
blitzen
es ist ja tatsächlich so dass Königin
Margaret von Dänemark jetzt nach dem
ablehnen der Queen die am längsten
amtierende weibliche Staatschefin der
Welt ist ja da sind wir Prinz Harry
vor ihm sein Bruder
[Musik]
läuft der Sohn von Prinzessin Anne und
neben Peter fehlt neben Peter läuft dann
der Sohn von Prinzessin Margaret der
Schwester der Königin
und ausnahmsweise halten Prinz Harry und
Meghan mal kein Handy also angemessen
dem anderen nicht und hier sieht man
Charlotte die kleine Prinzessin
vor den beiden haben wir Prinz Edward
gesehen mit seiner Frau Sophie von
Wessex
vier Milliarden Menschen auf der ganzen
Welt zu schätzt man sehen jetzt gerade
diese Bilder ja dagegen ist Super Bowl
final nichts ne
ich glaube das größte Medienspektakel
was glaube ich je gegeben hat in der
Welt wir müssen auch noch mal darauf
eingehen wie wichtig die Westminster
Abbey für die Queen war wie viel sich
dort für Sie abgespielt hat sie wurde
dort gekrönt ganz plötzlich war sie eine
so junge Königin Tanja sie hat dort
geheiratet und jetzt
sind alle dort versammelt um sich dort
von ihr zu verabschieden
US-Präsident Joe Biden haben wir gesehen
Emanuel macrons Deutschland angereist
Frank-Walter Steinmeier hier sehen wir
schon auch gezeichnet King Charles the
third und Camila neben ihm
dahinter Prinzessin an
das ist ja auch ganz schwierig ne er hat
ja so ein straffes Programm die ganze
Zeit und man hat gar nichts für sich
selbst die Zeit einfach mal zu
reflektieren dass die eigene Mutter
gestorben ist und man hat so viele
Verpflichtungen also dass das kein
Wunder wenn ich dass er doch recht
leicht gezeichnet ist aussieht ne
große Aufgabe auf den kleinen Prinz
George den wir hier ein Bild dran sehen
da auch Kate und
[Musik]
jetzt wird der Sarg hineingetragen und
dann
folgt ein Trauergottesdienst eine Stunde
lang hier noch mal einen Blick auf die
prachtvolle Krone
zahlreichen Diamanten mit violetten samt
68 Perlen
zuletzt hat die Queen sie gar nicht mehr
tragen können weil ihr die sieht so
schwer war sie wird ja übrigens zwei
Schmuckstücke mit in den Sarg nehmen
nämlich ihren Ehering und Perlenohrringe
die ihr Philip mal geschenkt hat und der
Verlobungsring von ihr den Komfort
princess and
[Musik]
beeindruckender Blick jetzt von oben
hinein
in Westminster Abbey ist diese Mauern
schon alles gesehen haben
und jetzt dort 2000 Gäste dort
versammelt den Manuel macron
US-Präsident Joe Biden die gesamte Royal
Family alle Königshäuser die man so
kennt und sogar der japanische Kaiser
japanische Kaiser dort
alle Regierungschefs
Staatslenker jetzt dort versammelt in
diesem so historischen Tag an diesen
jahrhundert Tag der große Abschied von
Queen Elizabeth der zweiten 96 Jahre
wurde sie als 70 Jahre Sassi auf dem
britischen Thron
in grave
Thanksgiving in Trauer und Dankbarkeit
sind wir hier in diesem Gotteshaus
gemeinsam zusammengekommen und zu beten
um uns zu erinnern und Hoffnung
auszudrücken
an diesem Ort wo Königin Elisabeth
verheiratet wurde und gekrönt sind wir
aus aller Herrenländer der ganzen Welt
zusammengekommen aus dem Commonwealth
und aller Länder dieser Welt und
gemeinsam Trauerarbeit zu leisten
aber auch um gemeinsam ihren langen
Leben zu gedenken und
sie Gott zu überlassen unserem Schöpfer
und Retter voller Dankbarkeit erinnern
wir uns
an den großen Dienst den sie ihrem Land
und uns allen
geleistet hat als Königin
und für das kommende
an die Kraft mit der sie ihrem Volk
immer gedient hat daher konstant für das
immerwährende Beispiel christlicher
Nächstenliebe dass sie uns alle gelehrt
hat die Liebe für ihre Familie
und alles was sie getan hat für die
Dinge die ihr wichtig waren jetzt werden
wir in Stille daran denken und dafür
beten an all die Gründe für die wir
Danke sagen wollen alles was uns an sie
erinnert wir werden beten für alle
Familienmitglieder der Königsfamilie
und dafür dass die Königin nun in guten
Händen ist bei Gott
unseres Herren Jesus Christus der sein
Sohn hat auferstehen lassen
in dir soll alles Leben obwohl es stirbt
soll das ewige Leben haben und deiner
Hand du hast uns durch deine
Apostel beigebracht
die Nächstenliebe immer in die Mitte zu
stellen
zu sprechen wir bitten Dich
heiliger Vater erlöse uns von der Sünde
auf den Gerechten weg so dass an dem Tag
an dem wir diese Welt verlassen wir in
dir ruhen dürfen das ist unsere Hoffnung
dass unsere Schwester die Königin das
auch tut
am letzten Tag ihres jüngsten Gerichtes
und dass sie deinen Segen empfängt
durch deinen geliebten Sohn zu uns
gebracht hast
ihr gesegneten Kinder des Vaters das
Königreich erwartet von erwartet euch
vorbereitet für euch seit dem Anbeginn
der Welt
das Gewehre uns heiliger Vater durch
Jesus Christus unseren Retter Amen
[Musik]
jetzt auferstanden von den Toten
und zur ersten Frucht geworden
derer die schlafen
durch den Menschen ist der Tod in die
Welt gekommen
und durch ihn ist die Auferstehung von
den Toten Wirklichkeit geworden
denn wir Adam müssen alle sterben
auch Jesus Christus und dennoch sollen
in ihm alle leben
doch jeder Mensch
in seiner eigenen Folge
Christus ist die erste Frucht
und die die nach ihm kommen und Jesus
Christus sind folgen ihm
und dann folgt das Ende
wenn er dem Herrn das Königreich
dargelegt haben wird ihm dem Vater
[Musik]
wenn alle Regentschaft beendet ist und
alle Macht
Rain denn er soll regieren
bis alle Feinde ihm unterworfen sind
der letzte Feind der zerstört werden
wird ist der Tod
must put on denn dieses korrumpierte
muss enden
und dieses Sterbliche
[Musik]
muss unsterblich werden
in corruption
wenn also die Lüge menschlich geworden
ist und Fleisch geworden ist dann soll
Unsterblichkeit sie ersetzen
und so ist es geschrieben der Tod
wird verschluckt durch den Sieg
wo ist dein Schwert
oh Grab
wo ist dein Sieg das Ding
das Schwert des Todes ist die Sünde
und die Stärke der Sünde
ist vergangen
sei also Gott der uns den Sieg gegeben
hat durch unseren Herrn Jesus Christus
deswegen meine geliebten Brüder
bleibt standhaft
bewegt euch nichts
und immer erfüllt von der Arbeit des
Herrn als Mensch
denn so gut er auch eure Arbeit kennt er
weiß diese Arbeit
ist in seinem Sinne Dank sei Gott
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mein Herz
nicht aufhören glaube stattdessen an
Gott und Glaube an mich im Haus meines
Vaters sind viele Paläste wäre es nicht
so hätte ich euch dies bereits gesagt
ich bereite euch einen Ort vor für euch
im Namen des Herrn und wenn ich gehe um
diesen Ort vorzubereiten werde ich
wiederkehren
und euch in die Arme nehmen denn wo ich
bin sollst auch du sein und wo ich
hingehe sollst auch du hingehen
thomas hat es so geschrieben
Herr wir wissen nicht wohin du gehen
wirst und woher können wir es auch
wissen jesus
hat zu Thomas gesagt ich bin der Weg die
Wahrheit und das Licht
unsere Faser kein Mensch kommt nach dem
Vater außer er geht an mir vorbei
hätte er mich gekannt und meine Wege
gekannt hätte er auch meinen Vater
gekannt
und von nun an kennst du ihn wirst ihn
gesehen haben und Philipp sagte zu
Thomas Herr
zeig uns den Vater
und das wird uns genügen
und Jesus antwortete ihm
war ich nicht lange genug bei euch und
dennoch Philipp kennst du mich nicht er
der mich gesehen hat hat den Vater
gesehen
dank sei dem Herrn
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kam völlig Spirit komm heiliger Geist
and fill Achat und erfülle unsere Herzen
mit dem Band
deine heilenden Liebe Amen
die Art und Weise wie viele Anführer
sich verhalten im Leben ist es die
während ihrer Lebenszeit gefeiert werden
aber dann vergessen wenn sie sterben
das ist aber nicht die Art und Weise für
diejenigen die im Dienste unseres Gottes
stehen egal ob sie bekannt sind oder
nicht denn für diejenigen ist der Tod
einfach nur die Tür in zum nächsten
Schritt und unsere Königin ihre Majestät
die Königin hat als sie 21 wurde mal
gesagt dass ihr ganzes Leben uns allen
gewidmet sein würde uns allen
Großbritannien und dem Commonwealth und
man sieht es doch selten dass ein
Versprechen so stark gehalten wurde sehr
wenige Anführer auf dieser Welt haben
das so erlebt und deswegen ist auch ganz
klar dass nur wenige Anführer auf dieser
Welt wenige Staatschef so viel Liebe
empfangen wie unsere Königin
und eben in der Lesung haben wir ja
gehört dass Jesus seinen Anhängern nicht
sagt wie man ihn verehren soll sondern
wen man verehren soll das hat er gesagt
er hat gesagt ich Jesus bin der Weg die
Wahrheit und das Licht
das Beispiel ihrer Majestät hatte nichts
mit ihrer Position und ihrem Rang zu tun
auch nicht mit ihrer Ambition aber damit
wem sie gefolgt ist im Leben dem lieben
Gott und ich weiß dass seine Majestät
König Charles III diesen Glauben teilt
den gleichen wie seine Mutter diese Idee
von Dienst und Pflicht
1953 hat die Königin ihre eigene Krönung
damit begonnen in Stille zu beten da
drüben am Hochaltar
ihre Allianz mit Gott
jemand anders eine Allianz mit ihr
begonnen hat das heißt sie war immer da
und das ist auch der Grund warum sie so
vielen Leuten ihren Dienst erweisen
konnte sie waren begründet in der
Tatsache dass sie immer Jesus Christus
gefolgt ist Gott selbst der gesagt hat
dass er nicht auf die Welt gekommen ist
um bedient zu werden sondern um zu
dienen
und sein Leben gegeben hat als Pfand für
so viele
Menschen die sich in den Liebenden
Dienst des Herrn stellen diese Menschen
sind selten die
liegen die im Dienst der Liebe ihre
Länder anführen das ist etwas Seltenes
wie auch immer der Fall ist
müssen wir uns in Erinnerung rufen dass
die die am meisten lieben in der Zeit in
der sie mächtig sind nicht vergessen
werden sondern für immer erinnert werden
und die Trauer dieses heutigen Tages
zeigt dass die Trauer die wir alle
spüren und die in der ganzen Welt
spürbar ist im Commonwealth und in der
ganzen Welt
diese Trauer kommt aus der Pracht ihres
Lebens dieses Lebens das sie für uns
geführt hat und jetzt ist sie uns
genommen
sie war froh
präsent wenn sie da war sie hat so viele
Leben berührt so viele Menschen und
Herzen und wir beten heute ganz
besonders für ihre ganze Familie die
auf einer Art und Weise trauen als wären
wir alle auf der Welt eine große Familie
so viele Familien auf der ganzen Welt
die selbst jemanden vor diese Zeit
verloren haben auch für die wollen wir
heute beten
aber im Fall dieser Familie der königst
Familie
lasst uns erinnern daran dass sie im
Scheinwerferlicht trauern müssen vor
unserer aller Augen möge Gott ihre
Herzen heilen und ihnen neue Hoffnung
und Zuversicht geben
die Rede ihre Majestät der Königin
während Corona endete mit den Worten wir
werden uns wiedersehen das waren Worte
der Hoffnung
von einem Lied des Herrn es war
christliche Hoffnung
und das bedeutet sich einer Sache sicher
zu sein von der man noch gar nicht
sicher weiß ob sie passiert aber dennoch
daran zu glauben und so verhält es sich
auch mit Jesus Christus er ist
auferstanden er wusste nicht ob es so
sein würde aber er hat daran geglaubt in
Ewigkeit
wie das Weihnachtslied
vor alle Seelen ihn empfangen
ruhig wird der Herr sich in unsere Mitte
Gesellen
und so werden wir alle das Gericht eines
Tages sehen wir werden ihm Gott
gegenübertreten
und ich sage wir alle sollten
uns etwas abschauen von der Hoffnung der
Königin
Service in life Dienst und Pflicht im
Leben Hoffnung im Tod
alle die sich am Beispiel der Königin
orientieren die an ihr Inspiration
finden können gemeinsam mit ihr sagen
wir werden uns wiedersehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in confidence and trust
Friday Überzeugung wollen wir jetzt zum
Vater beten
dadurch
für das lange leben von Königin
Elisabeth und ihre lange Regentschaft
wir erinnern uns dankbar an ihre
Geschenke an ihre Weisheit
an ihre Würde
und an die Pflicht die sie getan hat
oh Gott guter Gott
das aufrichtig und wahr ist
nimm unseren Dank an für die Geschenke
des Herzens unter Gedanken die du deiner
Tochter Elisabeth gegeben hast
und die sie in ihren Worten unter uns
geteilt hat
und gib uns dass wir eines Tages selbst
die Gnade haben
unser eigenes Leben auf Einklang mit
deinem Willen zu Leben für das Gute der
andere
und als treue Diener in deinem Glauben
bis ans Ende unseres Lebens durch Jesus
Christus unseren Herrn Amen
t in gods love and compassion voller
Vertrauen in die Liebe Gottes
lasst uns beten für all diejenigen
deren Herzen schwer sind die jetzt
trauern allmächtiger Gott
[Musik]
und gebe aller Güte
unser Trainings beten wir zu dir mit all
denen die jetzt trauern
das alle Güten und alle Sorgen von dir
ausgehen dass sie getröstet werden und
ihre Herzen nicht mehr weinen durch
Jesus Christus unseren Herrn Amen
beten wir für seine Majestät König
Charles den dritten und die ganze
Königsfamilie
dass sie alle die immerwährende Kraft
der Liebe Gottes kennen
und Gott als Gefährten wahrnehmen
allmächtiger Gott
Brunnen aller Güte
bescheiden bitten wir dich segne unseren
herrscherkönig Charles und die Queen
Konzert Camilla William Prinz von Wales
und die ganze Königsfamilie
gib ihnen deinen Heiligen Geist
bereicher sie mit deiner himmlischen
Gnade und mach sie reichen mit Glück und
Zufriedenheit
bring sie in dein ewig während des
Königreich durch Jesus Christus unseren
Herrn Amen
in recognition of Queen Elizabeth
Service
für den Dienst den Königin Elisabeth II
unserem Land geleistet hat
wollen wir uns freuen
für das Mitleid dass sie gehabt hat wenn
ihre Subjekte gelitten haben für den Rat
den sie sich
von allen geholt hat dass sie zugehört
hat für den Reichtum unserer Nation für
all das danken wir dir allmächtiger Gott
dessen Willen es ist dass alle deine
Kinder dir dienen indem sie sich
gegenseitig dienen Blicke liebevoll auf
uns wie wir hier beten für diese Nation
geht allen Mitgliedern dieser Nationen
die Gnade gemeinsam zu arbeiten mit
ehrlichen und treuen Herzen wenn einer
sich um das Wohl des Anderen kümmert
immer auf der Suche nach deinem
Königreich und seiner Gerechtigkeit
sollen sie alle Dinge besitzen die sie
brauchen
für ihr tägliches gut durch Jesus
Christus unseren Herrn Amen
auch
für den Glauben den Königin Elisabeth II
an das kommen wollt hatte über die ganze
Zeit diese regiert hat für die Art und
Weise wie sie regiert hat für die
Reichen Bände die sie geknüpft hat mit
allen Menschen innerhalb dieses
Commonwealth und immer aufrechterhalten
hat
allmächtiger und ewiger Gott hör unser
Gebet für das Komments
und gib es gib ihm die Kraft deiner
Weisheit inspiriere hast durch deine
macht damit Gerechtigkeit und das
Gemeinwohl immer über allem stehen gib
allen Mitgliedern des Commonwealth den
Geist der gegenseitigen Ehre und das
Respekts und gib uns allen
Kraft und Gnade immer danach zu streben
Gerechtigkeit aufrecht zu erhalten für
den Frieden für
die Ehre und in deinem Namen Armen
wir danken Gott
Königin Elisabeth II die Loyalität des
Glaubens den Sieg geerbt hat durch ihre
Taufe und Konfirmation und der bei ihrer
Krönung noch einmal bestätigt wurde
dafür dass Sie immer geglaubt hat dass
sie ihren Gott hoch gehalten hat
Elisabeth II hat Glauben gehalten und
den Glauben verteidigt in der Kirche
Englands Vater wir glauben an dich wir
bitten Dich in
dein Haus die Kirche stark zu machen
die elisabeth ist getan hat und durch
deinen Schutz dafür zu sorgen dass sie
nun frei von allen Schmerzen ist in all
ihren guten Werken
Ehre sei dir woher durch Jesus Christus
unseren Herrn Amen
beten wir auch für die Gnade die wir
selbst bekommen sollen als diejenigen zu
leben in Einheiten mit den Heiligen und
der Auferstehung zum ewigen Leben
gib uns heute und an dem letzten Tag den
wir erwachen
Eingang in dein Haus
in dein ewiges Tor um in deinem Haus zu
wohnen
wo keine Dunkelheit herrschen soll und
keine Verwirrung
wo wir alle gleich im Lichte stehen
sollen wo kein Geräusch und keine Stille
ist
aber nur eine gleiche Musik
keine Angst und keine Hoffnungen
nur ein gemeinsamer einziger Besitz kann
Ende und kann beginnen
nur eine gleiche Ewigkeit
in deiner Nähe und in der Nähe deines
Königreiches eine Welt ohne Ende Amen
[Musik]
nicht
nur
[Musik]
in confidence
voller Kraft und Hoffnung wollen wir nun
beten
guter Gott wir bitten Dich in den Worten
die du uns gelehrt hast
vater unser im Himmel geheiligt werde
dein Name dein Reich komme dein Wille
geschehe wie im Himmel so auf Erden
unser tägliches Brot gib uns heute und
vergib uns unsere Schuld
wir vergeben unseren Schuldigern und
führe uns nicht in Versuchung sondern
erlöse uns von den Bösen
denn dann ist das Reich und die Kraft
und die Herrlichkeit in Ewigkeit Amen
[Musik]
empfehlen wir der Gnade Gottes
unserem Schöpfer und Retter die Seele
von Elisabeth unserer Verstorbenen
Königin
die Vater himmlischer Vater König aller
Könige Herr aller Herren und Geber allen
Lebens du hast in all deiner Güte und
Gnade den Menschen nach deinem Bild
geschaffen und in deiner unendlichen
Liebe und das Leben geboten und gegeben
durch Jesus Christus unseren Herrn
dessen versprechen du einlöst und damit
vertrauen wir dir die Seele unserer
Schwester Elisabeth II die von uns
gegangen ist an in deine gnädige Hund
nimm sie an lass sie auferstehen gib ihr
Teilhabe am ewigen Leben wo sie Jesus
Christus unter die Augen treten und ihn
wiedersehen soll der gestorben ist für
uns alle zu unserer aller Rettung lass
sie regieren
in ewiger Ehre amen Geld
christliche Seele aus dieser Welt im
Namen des Herrn des Allmächtigen der
dich erschaffen hat
im Namen von Jesus Christus Sohn des
lebendigen Gottes der gelitten hat für
dich
und im Namen des Heiligen Geistes
der über dich geschüttet wurde und der
dich gesalbt hat in Kommunion mit all
den gesegneten heiligen
begleitet von den Engeln und Erzengeln
und allen Armeen des himmlischen Führers
lass dein Glauben ewiglich sein und sei
ewig in Frieden im himmlischen Jerusalem
Amen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gib uns allen lebenden die Gnade und für
die von uns gegangenen die Ruhe und der
König gibt
die Kirche zurück wie allen Menschen in
Frieden
auf allen Sündern gib Leben und Reue
im Namen des Vaters und des Sohnes und
des Heiligen Geistes
deren Segen soll immer in eurer Mitte
wohnen und bei euch bleiben Amen
[Musik]
gleich Schweigen
woran das frauensignal lässt Post hier
durch die Westminster Abbey Tönen
[Musik]
und danach das eine Minute der Stille
geben im Gedenken an Queen Elizabeth II
zwei Minuten Stille im ganzen Land jetzt
zu ehren
der Verstorbenen Königin
2000 Gäste in Westminster Abbey haben
sich erhoben
den Kopf gesenkt und stillen Gedenken
und hier sehen wir
Schweigen dort in der Westminster Abbey
im gesamten Land Stille für die Königin
und gleich wird die Hymne angestimmt
ganz bewegender Höhepunkt in diesem
Gedenk Gottesdienst gleich werden wir
hören Gott save the king zu Ehren von
King Charles the third dort in
Westminster Abbey
jetzt lassen wir diese Bilder diese
Bilder der Stille auf uns wirken
die Welt steht still für zwei Minuten zu
ehren
der Queen
wir blicken auch auf die Straßen von
London die Straßen der Hauptstadt
tausende Menschen dort
vereint für diesen Abschied
[Musik]
[Applaus]
god save the king die Nationalhymne in
der Westminster Abbey
die auch das Ende dieses
Gedenkgottesdienstes einläutet
berührender Gänsehaut Moment diese
Live-Bilder aus der Westminster Abbey
eben gerade haben wir auch sehr berührt
den neuen König King Charles befüllt
gesehen
bei der Hymne und jetzt
eine letzte doodlesack Melodie zu
ehrende Queen die sich diesem
Gedenkgottesdienst
kurz und nicht langweilig gewünscht
hat 2000 Menschen dort sind erschienen
die mächtigsten Menschen der Welt die
jetzt Abschied nehmen von ihr
und Königin Elisabeth der zweiten ihr
sagt schmückt mit Blumen aus den
diversen Schlössern aus den Gärten dort
all das hat King Charles
für sie so arrangieren lassen man
vermutet der Brief in der Mitte der
Blumen auch ein Brief von ihm an seine
Mutter
ganz London macht sich jetzt bereit
viele Tränen wie wir auch sehen
berührende Momente für die Menschen dort
auf den Straßen
wenn der sagt der Queen jetzt gleich
Westminster Abbey verlassen wird dieser
Ort
an dem sie vor über 70 Jahren zur
Königin gekrönt wurde und er sagt macht
sich dann auf er wird getragen über die
Prachtstraße the mall zur Prozession zum
Wellington Arch wird er gebracht und
wenn er dort angekommen ist wird er
ungebettet in einen Leichenwagen und
dann erfolgt der Transport nach Winsor
wo es für die Queen dann weitergeht
wir verfolgen hier diese Live-Bilder aus
der Westminster Abbey mit unserer
bildshow-chefin Tanja mai mit unserer
Society Expertin Bettina von
Schimmelmann jetzt die letzten Minuten
des Gedenkgottesdienstes
ein großer
weil auch trauriger Höhepunkt dort in
der Westminster Abbey
wo zahlreiche Royals alle Königshäuser
versammelt sind alle mächtigen und
wichtigen Menschen dieser Erde und jetzt
setzt man sich
dort in Bewegung
im gerade haben wir auch
die Royals gesehen King Charles der
natürlich nicht mitgesungen hat bei god
save the king neben ihm seine Queen
concert Camilla
William und Kate sind dort die Kinder
Prinzessin Charlotte und Prinz George
mitgebracht
einen kleinen Louis vier Jahre alt zu
Hause gelassen
Willi und Harry
die beiden Brüder den wir hier natürlich
auch ganz genau in diesen schwierigen
Stunden ins Gesicht blicken wollen
[Applaus]
Meghan
die dort ist die ganze Familie die
Abschied nimmt
von der Königin
eine Stunde lang ging dieser
Gottesdienst
und jetzt
folgt die Prozession dort
durch London den ganzen Tag wird diese
Reise Tanja der Queen dauern bis sie am
Ende dann ihre letzte Ruhe findet neben
ihrer großen Liebe neben Prinz Philip
ich glaube die Queen wäre zufrieden wenn
es diesen Gottesdienst mit hätte erleben
dürfen sie hatte sich ja ein
Gottesdienst gewünscht der ihm nicht
allzu langweilig sein soll und ich fand
es war sehr kurzweilig es war sehr
feierlich und auch voller Würde der
Königin angemessen aber trotzdem eben
auch die Musik die Sie ausgewählt hat
alles ein sehr würdevoller Abschied aber
auch ein sehr liebevoller Abschied und
jetzt geht ja die Prozession geht ja
jetzt etwa eine Stunde lang wird bis der
sagt dann verladen wird in den
Leichenwagen und was ich ganz schön
finde eigentlich hätte die Route ja nach
Windsor über die Autobahn führen sollen
aber man hat sich jetzt doch entschieden
eine andere Route zu wählen das eben
möglichst viel Landstraße gefahren wird
das noch mehr Menschen Abschied nehmen
können von ihrer Königin
[Musik]